hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about feedback inhibition this is an
important process in the cell that has a
lot of regulatory repercussions so first
let's talk about what feedback
inhibition is it is a situation in which
you have some kind of metabolic pathway
where you have an initial substrate
multiple enzymes that act on multiple
intermediates to reach an end product so
feedback inhibition is when the final
product that in the product when that
final product actually inhibits the
pathway upstream that would be if this
end product was actually capable of
inhibiting enzyme 1 the first enzyme
that acts on the initial substrate
now what's the point of this why would
the cell have metabolic pathways where
the end product basically turns the
entire pathway off and keeps it from
producing more end product well it has
to do with waste feedback inhibition
prevents a cell from wasting things
specifically from wasting energy and
material resources that is from wasting
energy producing these enzymes and
having these enzymes act on these
different intermediates and preventing
the weights of material resources means
preventing the waste of things like the
amino acids that are used to make these
enzymes things like the precursors that
are made to work on these intermediates
etc and so the reason the feedback
inhibition prevents a cell from wasting
these things is because at a certain
point the end product is no longer
needed that means that this metabolic
pathway will run and run and run and
make loss of the end product and at some
point the end product will no longer be
needed by the cell anymore and since
it's not needed it won't be used by the
cell this means that the end product its
concentration in the cell will increase
and that is what allows it to inhibit
that first enzyme to keep even more
unnecessary end product from being made
an example of this is when high ATP
concentrations inhibit an enzyme
required in glycolysis remember that in
cellular respiration there are three
main steps
there's glycolysis the Krebs
goal and the electron transport chain
which is what powers oxidative
phosphorylation with ATP synthase if you
want to refresh yourself on some of
those details please see my video on
cellular respiration but basically those
different stages all produce some ATP
and so when the cell needs ATP it wants
cellular respiration to run and produce
what it means however when the cell no
longer needs ATP or when the ATP being
produced reaches too high of a
concentration in the cell that ATP will
actually inhibit an enzyme that is
required in the first stages of cellular
respiration again preventing the cell
from wasting energy and material
resources running that complex cellular
respiration product so that is it for
today biology professor thanks for
watching and I hope you learned a lot